so listen in honor of Lily's perfume and
Peter's eyebrows I love them we have a
little game called I know those brows
are you ready come on over okay Peter I
think
[Applause]
he didn't think my show is we thought we
were cheap what he played a game and
unless we built this for him so free
billing yeah yeah what he wants to do is
win but major all right here we go
here's how the game works
a pair of famous eyebrows will appear on
the screen whoever buzzes you got to
push the buzzer whoever buzzes in first
gets to guess if you get it right you
get a point there are no steals most
points win and we're playing for the
audience so don't fail them all right if
Lily wins all the women in the audience
are walking out of here with a
personally signed bottle of Lily's Haven
perfume all the men get her gender
neutral summit fragrance also autograph
if I win I get total bragging rights and
let's be honest I'll probably give you
all a present all right let's see the
first picture I'm gonna do this while
drinking Wow
[Applause]
okay okay I know you have some wine too
we're fancy Lilly I'm sure it's
sparkling into the red so little cop
we're seriously fancy here's the next
one here we go okay I would have said
Mario Mario okay next photo okay okay
let's keep going you picked all you open
it all I'm gonna count to five I swear
to God I didn't see them I disagree
let's keep going oh okay it's one of the
customers you guys Ernie I actually
don't know that way I didn't know that
next picture Billy I love her I love her
okay next net moving on Wayne Johnson
[Applause]
the person that brings people on just to
beat them in game although I am totally
that person let's see the next one oh I
know this one a photo it's like she is
amazing hi I don't know which one but
she is so hot her eyes are like you okay
here's the final picture why is that no
it looks like I have no idea I actually
don't know Andy Ronnie
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this